today's flynn news has the media of
course going absolutely bonkers and
they're excited about the possibility
that this could be curtains for
President Trump there aren't many more
dots right after Mike Flynn right your
dots go to Kushner and then the
president there really are no other dots
here this is a case that reaches
directly into the heart of the Trump
administration into the Oval Office
people now who have who have believed
that the president sort of loose way
with information and facts with his best
defense now think that the president is
in danger and exposed I do agree this is
a big moment where if you're on the
fence you start to think geez is this
whole thing going down is it Watergate
know for the contrary everything's
Watergate nothing's Watergate when
everything's Watergate here's how famed
former federal federal prosecutor Andy
McCarthy put it his own perspective in
national review he said for all the
furor we have a small potatoes plea in
Flynn's case just as we did in
Papadopoulos this case despite extensive
collusion evidence and of course joining
us now with reaction former federal
prosecutor Jo Geneva and sole
Weisenberger served as deputy
independent counsel and the Whitewater
investigation of Bill Clinton okay Joe
is the truth somewhere between this is
worse than Watergate and this is small
potatoes where are we on this well it's
very important to realize the general
Flynn did exactly what Papadopoulos did
he pleaded guilty to conduct that was
legal he lied about conduct that was
legal I knew his all of Flynn's
conversations with the ambassador to
Russia were perfectly legal during the
transition period and even before it's
not a crime to communicate with an
ambassador of a foreign country about
foreign policy when you are the foreign
policy adviser to the incoming president
so I don't know why he lied it's it's
inconceivable to me if he had told the
truth there would be no crime other than
the Feres stuff that about his failing
to register but this is enough this
foreign agent this is a nothing burger
and
all this time this is what he gets out
of Flynn it tells me that there's not
much there and it certainly can't
involve the president because the
president has the authority to do all
the things that he did and as far as
Kushner goes that if there's anything
with Kushner it involves transactions
involving real estate deals 10-15 years
ago
saw you you felt it all day long
building building building Jared Kushner
directed you know calls to Russia first
of all even if that were true they were
sitting around a table somewhere Jared
Kushner and a bunch of people said well
we should probably reach out to Russia
on this it find out what's going on with
all the Security Council members on this
Israeli sanctions thing because none of
us want Israel to have more sanctions
put on them big deal so what if he did
well that is legitimate said there's
nothing wrong with that you could do
that all day long when you're it when
your transition team official well
there's nothing wrong with quote
communicating with the Russians in fact
in most instances there's nothing wrong
with a private citizen communicating
with the Russians now if you believe
what is in the factual basis or
statement of the offense of the Flyn
papers they they did violate the letter
conceivably there was a violation of the
language of the Logan Act and you're
hearing a lot about the Logan act but as
you know the Logan Act has never been
successfully used against anyone and the
last time anyone was even indicted under
it was 1852
so if Muller is thinking of indicted
anybody under the Logan Act to me and
I've been a defender of log of mother I
think he's an honorable guy but if he is
even thinking of prosecuting anybody for
violating the Logan act I will instantly
denounce him because it will show such
bad faith that it's unbelievable to me
well I would agree with that except
here's here's the problem for mr. Muller
you can't violate the Logan Act when
you're in the transition team because
because you're a government employee you
get a green check
when you're on the transition team you
are a special government employee they
can communicate with anybody they want
and I agree with saw the Logan acts
never been enforced and if Muller were
to use it in this case then if I were
the president I would fire him now Andy
McCarthy his point is that if there was
some big scheme here guys
they wouldn't have allowed him to plead
to one count of lying to the FBI which
is a great point I mean there is it if
there was evidence of a scheme occlusion
they wouldn't have had to do the plea
this way and they would have gotten a
lot more so his view is that it's it's
so far at the very least so far they
don't really have anything on the
collusion conspiracy to influence the
election front
they got Flynn for whatever reason he
decides to lie about conversations they
could have done anyway so that's the
weird thinking I got it I got to make
you guys laugh on a Friday okay this is
gonna make it laughs I'm ready
joy and I cuz why isn't no saw is a
great sense of humor he's very serious
but is a great sense of humor joy behar
heard about the news of the Flynn plea
reading an ABC report today on the view
let's watch oh my god oh breaking news
ABC news Brian Ross is reporting Michael
Flynn promised full cooperation to the
Muller team and is prepared to testify
that as a candidate Donald Trump
directed him to make contact with the
Russians
like she just won its Publishers
Clearing House over there guys
but ABC by the way had to come out
immediately and say it was this was not
during the campaign this was actually
during the transition but this is the
level of there it is yeah the clarified
out to read the whole thing it wouldn't
it wouldn't sorry it wouldn't even
matter if it was in the campaign
sorry didn't matter it was in the
campaign there's nothing wrong quote
with talking to the Russians all right
it depends on what on what you say so
but the earlier point you made Lara is
very important that Annie McCarthy made
this is very striking to me the plea
agreement says that Flynn is only
protected from future prosecution based
on items that are in the statement of
the offense that's the key document
there's nothing in the statement of the
offense about collusion during the
campaign nothing so unless there is a
completely separately sealed completely
standalone plea agreement for Flynn that
it's sealed which would be almost
unheard of I think Joe will agree with
me it means that Flynn has no knowledge
Flender was a key figure in the campaign
has no knowledge of any collusion with
Russia during the campaign any collusion
nothing Berger but me you're the
well-respected Bob Muller
so far is coming up with very little in
my opinion but the hyper hyperbolic
response by the media I mean these
people are completely unhinged the facts
are irrelevant analysis irrelevant just
jump right to the gallows for Trump
that's where they're going gentlemen
thank you and Saul I knew I could make
you laugh I got it I got it out here